hey leute und willkommen zu meiner
vorstellung zum neuen minecraft snapshot
12 bis 36 a der soeben vor ein paar
stunden erschienen ist da haben wir
schon ein interessantes schaf schwein
und darum es auch ein schwein willst bei
der schweine neue gaal jedenfalls wollte
ich euch die änderung mal ganz kurz
vorstellen und ich würd sagen wir fangen
direkt an und zwar der bacon blog oder
becken blog bzw das leuchtfeuer nun
endlich eine neue textur ihr findet es
wie immer hier oben unter sonstiges oder
verschiedenes und dann ist hier der
block und ihr seht es hat man endlich
eine texturen ich finde die textur
eigentlich richtig geiles auf jeden fall
besser als vorher wie immer auf seine
pyramide drauf bauen leuchtet der halt
nach ganz ganz oben
so trefft ihr euch den ihr habt ihr
einfach glas usw
und hier obsidian und dann braucht ihr
noch einen etat stern wofür oder wodurch
man den bekommt weiß noch nicht genau
auf jeden fall irgendwie aus dem netz
ich glaube der wird teilweise gedroppt
oder den findet man da irgendwo wenn ihr
das genau ist dann bitte einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
da werde ich euch selbst verbunden ich
hatte keine zeit das herauszufinden aber
jedenfalls crafted man den sich so und
dann bekommt man halt so einen dicken
decken blog daraus nächste neuerung sind
so ein paar köpfe die man von den sachen
bekommt und zwar gibt es hier einen
wasserkopf ein zombie kopf ein spieler
kopf ein kluger kopf und ein skelett
kopf die kriegt man teilweise wenn man
skelette tötet und so weiter aber es ist
halt wirklich sehr sehr selten
die findet man hier in diesem moment
warte ich zeig euch das mal ganz kurz wo
waren das wo man das da war das als sich
unter dekoration darf man diese skeleton
diese verschiedenen köpfe dass es dieser
bilder skeleton kopf und was der macht
das zeige ich euch nachher noch die kann
man dann noch ganz normalen solche
bilderrahmen tun also die habe ich euch
ja noch ein auch noch nicht vorgestellt
also es gibt jetzt bilder waren einfach
rechts klick darauf und dann könnt ihr
da irgend einen block mit rechtsklick
darauf rein machen ich könnte es hier
wieder rechtsklick drauf machen dann
kann ich den drehen und so weiter also
ihr seht schon wie das ungefähr da ist
die mauern habe ich euch auch noch nicht
vorgestellt wurden auch schon letztes
mal vorgestellt da kann man nicht drüber
springen sind halt quasi sondern andere
art von zäunen gibt es einerseits hier
in ganz normal habe ich jetzt kaputt
gemacht und hier in moos naja so dann
gibt es wurden auch schon das letzte vor
allem zugefügt karotten und kartoffeln
und auch gebackene kartoffeln
vergiftete kartoffeln und auch eine
goldene karotte hier wird die textur
geändert bei der goldenen karotte und
man kann nun auch mit einer karotte und
eine angel moment ich zeig euch das mal
ganz kurz jetzt brauche ich noch in
kräftigen table so ich zeige euch das
mal so kann man sich eine karre
donnerstag machen dass die bewirkt es
ganz einfach wenn ihr damit auf dem
schwein drauf guckt dann läuft euch das
schwein hinterher
und wenn ihr euch einen sattel nehmt
moment nein da sattel und ihr nehmt die
phishing gute mit der karotte macht er
richtig drauf dann könnt ihr da hin wo
die karotte zeigt dahin läuft das
schwein das heißt wenn ich zum beispiel
da zum anderen scheinen will einfach die
karotte dahin zeigen
dann zieht das ungefähr so aus ist halt
ganz interessant ist auch ein bisschen
schneller als normal gehen und man
verbraucht dabei halt keine wie heißt es
von diesen hunger teilen und die laufen
euch halt auch hinterher also ein etwas
anderes als weizen sag ich mal so
eigentlich wollte ich euch schwein spawn
lassen aber hat jetzt hier schon da sind
na ja also das wollen die mir das nicht
mehr
übrigens diese köpfe hier die ihr hier
seht habe ich vorhin vergessen die könnt
ihr euch so auf dem kopf aufsetzen das
ist beim jetzt blöd weil ich habe mein
spiel beinhaltet eine maske das heißt
bei mir sieht ersetzt nicht ganz so
schön aus aber was ihr seht ich habe von
hinten jetzt ein krieg per kopf bei euch
wird das dann komplett rum sein
mitteldorf ich bin in skype noch komisch
wenn wir mal kurz beschäftigt so perfekt
also bei euch wird das dann besser
aussehen ihr seht schon ich habe das
hier drum herum also ist es einfach weil
mein kind so eine maske auf hat naja nun
kommen wir zu einer sache für die ich
mal ganz kurz in den net ag weil ich es
einfach authentischer finde und zwar
braucht ihr cent baut denen so auf und
dann braucht die wipper skeleton köpfe
die letzte da so drauf und dann habt ihr
den ritter boards also so spontan den
das ist ein elektrischer denke ich und
ihr könnt ihr dann ganz einfach wenn ihr
den schlag verliert der eigentlich leben
allerdings was ich ganz interessant
finde ist dass der oben sein leben
regeneriert jetzt greift er mich an ach
du scheiße jetzt sagt na ja gut ich
glaube ihr wisst was ihr mit diesem ding
anfangen könnte der verfolgt mich hilfe
und was ist auch gibt wenn ihr hier ist
gelte also ganz normale skelett spontan
etwas und dann kommen wir solche
komischen skelette die sind schwarz und
haben ein schwerter wenn ich mir jetzt
mal ganz kurz hier so ein schwert nehmer
und die damit noch kurz ein bisschen
punkig einmal ganz kurz die droppen
einer setzt kohle moment stoppt doch mal
das was ich da zeigen wollte und zwar
die drop noch teilweise ihre halb
kaputten schwerter dann und auch richtig
komische sachen den usa könnte ich auch
mal ganz kurz zu töten den habe ich auch
noch nicht da da hat er drei köpfe kann
halt auch auf mich drauf schießen also
und der kann übrigens auch blöcke
abbauen das seht ihr das ist relativ
laut der wir jetzt von mir fliehen
stell dich dem feld okay gut online
jetzt regenerierte sich glaube ich
wieder das heißt diese komische schicht
um sie in den rumpf oder wie man wenn
ihr genaueres wisse einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
gleich ist tot im moment jetzt und zack
zack
damals also erst per drop eine menge
erfahrung und ich weiß nicht in sachen
hochwasser des gedroppt 18 meter schnee
den etat stern hat er den etat stellen
gedroppt ich glaube schon dass der den
roboter müssen jetzt auch wer den etat
stern drop daher das ist sehr schön
na ja das waren erstmal so die ganzen
neuerungen es war jetzt das letzte video
vorkommen 2.0 also heute ist er der
sechste morgen am siebten kommt glaube
ich kein video dann am 8 kommt halt die
vorstellung von konz 2.0
am neunten geht's dann los mit ganz ganz
vielen neuen projekten und bitte hört
auf in die kommentare zu schreiben dass
das ja total tacke wird und dass jeder
wähler das nachmache wartet doch erst
mal den termin ab meine damen und herren
und urteilt dann danke schön
also wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich mal daumen hoch freuen
allgemeinen bewertung vielleicht in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr am besten
fanden fandet ihr das update unnötig
also ich verdiene den bacon blog auf
jeden fall sehr gut gelungen und diese
sachen als dekoration auf jeden fall
auch ganz interessant
ich finde eigentlich mal wieder ein
richtig tolles update schreibt einfach
eure meinung in die kommentare
wir sehen uns dann nach von 2.0 ein
kleiner nachtrag meinerseits noch ins
habe ich vergessen zu erwähnen dass nun
in mops tonnen bzw
in den kisten beim mops pollern nunmehr
items drin sind und dass man schicken
also wiener nur noch mitfahren kann das
habe ich vergessen zu sagen ich bitte
das zu entschuldigen
und ja